so
[Music]
foreign
so
the question is
just staying there
did you get behind them
is that accurate yes something
breaks the rule
you can't stop the movie
you can't do your waza like that it's
indicative of the fettered mind
and bracing angles
so instead of ground vectoring
you're bracing you can't move till he's
unpinned
so that you're unpinned okay
so he has to keep
but not like this virginia
okay
and not
like getting out of the way he pushes
and like
he has an open hand do you see
okay
i am
adhering
and moving him
even as his fingers are closed
it's not that i'm
pulling on his fingers
so inside of his grip
that starts the movement so i he
and then
this next ikea adhesion
is on the outside
on the outside here
this keeps me going
okay
then i enter over here
not pull
and he stops and then you enter straight
to his back
incorrect
and here
i hear the dirt behind him
sideways
so if he is at 12 o'clock i'm going to
actually enter somewhere
around 9 00 or 8 30.
okay all right
[Music]
these three things
while he's moving
to he keeps moving and three i keep
moving
so again never
stops
okay let's try
all right so
i guess the question would be uh sensei
how come you don't have to grab his
shoulder
okay
uh again
we're grabbing the shoulders it's a
pulling movement okay so pulling means
that i'm far away from him
that's how i can pull him okay
and pulling him to me
secondarily
it means that we have distance between
us how the distance get there because
we're heading in opposite directions
that's why i have to pull him to me and
the directions that were headed are
linear uh in their orientation so what i
do instead
is that i'm near him
and we're not linear in our orientation
we're circular and i'm close to him
okay
so as uh i coming around
i don't go here for example now i'm
moving in the opposite direction that
he's going okay
uh
let's rewind a little bit
so
as he's coming in this is already
turning um
as opposed to
maybe i did not step far
you see
but i left him here and i now did it
there okay and i'm gonna pull him
so i
that happened because my i was linear in
fashion as opposed to keep this going
around
[Music]
i want to be circular and then in order
to be circular i have to be close to him
there is a key that you can look for
usually people will have an anchored
elbow
you see this and this elbow is anchored
here
and uh
they'll go
like this
watch my elbow instead
the elbows up
because i'm not pulling
i'm doing an ikea adhesion in a
inward
so spiral
you actually have an inward spiral on
the second arm it's not a outward
pairing
i sat inward spiral this way
and the technique goes this is an outer
spiral
home
inward inward
[Music]
boom inward
so free yourself
to have your elbow up
start to turn on this spiral this way
won't be close
move behind him
[Music]
so key
start him although you're not out of the
way you will be okay
so
whom start him on the turn
do not wait for him to get completely
out of the way
start
burning
[Music]
you